un círculo con área 81 y tiene un sector
con un ángulo central de 350 grados esto
de aquí es el círculo y el sector es
esta región que está sombreada como con
un amarillo claro vale además nos dicen
que el ángulo es de 350 grados y nos
están marcando todo este ángulo de acá
vale es todo este ángulo es todo este
ángulo grandote
va nos preguntan cuál es el área del
sector y para esto lo que tenemos que
saber es que la razón del área del
sector entre el área total es igual a la
razón del ángulo que tenemos entre el
ángulo total de una circunferencia
déjame escribir esto por acá entonces
voy a tomar el color naranja tenemos que
el área del sector área del sector
héctor dividida entre el área total de
la circunferencia que en este caso nos
dicen que es 81 por pi entre 81 por pi
es igual a la razón entre el ángulo del
sector y el ángulo total es decir es
igual a 350 grados 350 grados dividido
entre 360 grados que tiene una
circunferencia 360 grados muy bien vamos
a determinar el área del sector para eso
tenemos que multiplicar por 81 pi de
este lado y de este lado también por 81
pi de este lado se cancela y de este
lado que queda bueno déjame tomar el
color naranja nos queda que el área que
el área del sector naval' le voy a poner
así es igual a haber 350 entre 360 es lo
mismo que 35 entre 36 entonces voy a
escribir así las cosas lo voy a poner
como 35
35 x 81 pero en vez de 81 voy a poner 9
por 99 por 9 y dividido dividido entre
36 entre 36 y bueno hice esto para
cancelar un poco de cosas 36 es 9 por 4
entonces puedo cancelar esto como 4 con
este 9 y arriba pues creo que ya no hay
nada ni que sea par ni múltiplo de 4
entonces ya tengo que hacer la
multiplicación 35 por 9 eso cuando este
es 350 menos 35 o sea 315 nos quedaría
315 por pi dividido entre 4 y de esta
forma el área de este sector es igual a
315 por pi por ti
dividido entre 4